So next round against Deadman Walking
from
Turkey, let's play against myself,
so to speak, yes he chooses
the very solid variant here, the games I do
n't always find a bit too
boring, but of course it's
quite
possible so I
can swap him too  you play F3 and then E4
or is that too
shaky knight F5 is also possible then
no yes it could be too risky
but I really don't want to let it be
swapped, I'm
sorry
so maybe you can even take it and
then do E4 come on
always was now a
Center so short ruchade or long
ruchade yes rather short he also
played the move G6 so let's see I'm going
straight towards
H6 he doesn't care about it
well
so
yes there are also various interesting breakthroughs here
E5 E5 F Knight G5 has  but still Queen
E7 I can also switch on Knight E4
but even then he still has Queen
E7
okay again make a reinforcement z
so yes so directly so directly I don't see
anything and then it's stupid if you don't
see anything
directly Tom was stupid to me 1 too,
well  You don't actually want to
play D5, yes, and I was really slow,
well, but he can still allow himself to do all that,
so calmly, yes, well,
I have to make a little progress here now,
even if that might
not be possible now or something like that
but something has to happen here on the
kingside like knight to
G5 yes even if it's very weak
I played really stupidly
tur1 or something like that that was
stupid
check
t now you're definitely standing
around in the area very very stupidly
and you really have  nothing
and
A7 now the chess here is also very
unpleasant yes he has that too
yes
Check
well Queen E3 is also another
chess J is just broken you can't
do anything oh so now D E3 and knight F4
so
not at all surprising that this is here
I mean, you're
not allowed either, but
check, D
G1, oh yes, I played that really
badly, really badly
Maybe I have to do H3 and do
n't allow runner G4 then the runner has
nothing to bite, that
was stupid. A1 was stupid breeding, for example,
well